[Music]
geo remember when you
mentioned on the show in the past how
you remember when
bottled water was a thing and everyone
thought it was ridiculous because water
is free
and it talks [ __ ] a bunch of [ __ ] i
never heard of that well everyone talks
about that everyone's scoffing at it
there's like stand-up comedy like oh my
god
something for free you're going to
charge us tonight i don't remember none
of that
you're the same age or close right
exactly the same way
isn't that still going on what bottled
water
don't people still like make fun of it
well now now it's more like an eco thing
they're like why are you wasting food
but back then the concept of bottling
something that's free
it was like the same response as when we
started hearing people go oh we're going
to bottle air
and like oh my god i could get air right
here yeah which they
they already have that canned air is a
thing but
now we have uh packaged
leaves huh packaged leaves i don't even
have leaves in my house like california
flammable you need this
leaves why regular old leaves at a
grocery store they started selling in
the uk
and they call it like autumn foliage
oh is it for decorations
that's what they're claiming it i
believe that but then people are like
you're
you're trying to it's like the version
of roses when you don't really love them
he's like here you need to leave
some [ __ ] i knew you were here breakup
it's a breakup bouquet it was there i
was just trying to find the right way
that's so
good start a store called the breakup
bouquet yeah that's kind of lit yeah
and it's all like get out of here no
yes what else could it be what else what
else
what else there's another one somewhere
i don't think it is cheesy [ __ ]
make like a tree and leaf no no like
another product that could banana
banana a bag of [ __ ] no make like a
banana and split yeah oh like a banana
sweet
banana like a little mini banana cheers
yeah yeah you give them that [ __ ] we're
splitting up
yeah you have like a bucket of ice and
be like get the hell out of here
get the hell out of here full get the
hell out of my life
that's funny yeah tail out of my life
but yeah so like i said this was a this
is a uk based super bowl another one
and oh really what is it it's so stupid
uh when you
when your best friend is dating a chick
he's not supposed to be with her
but you don't know how to tell him a
breakup you give him a a liver
[Laughter]
like the ground and stuff
oh [ __ ] lesson learned i'm not
interrupting anyone
good leave her yeah no that whole thing
was i was like yes i love this
i love all this because you see me
[ __ ] crashing
[Laughter]
okay so they were actually charging six
pounds for
this uh bouquet of leaves heavier so
it's about 7.50
whoa so they were like what the [ __ ] for
real seven dollars for leaves that i
could just pick up outside well to be
fair those are really nice leaves that's
what people were saying they're like
these are high quality
yeah for real because usually if you
look at leaves outside there are holes
from like bugs eating them or whatever
they're like all crunchy these look like
cream on the other side
cream leaves yeah man showing the back
they do look nice
okay so what is it really like
decoration yeah yeah they were saying
that
they decided to to provide this at their
grocery store because
there were people that were requesting
it apparently can i have some
leaves this [ __ ] i want to leave her
they were like
a bag of actual leaves i get it because
when you're putting together a bouquet
like
have you seen people get down with
bouquets like a homemade bouquet
what do you mean homemade yeah like you
do it yourself yeah and then people get
really down on it and then they'll add
like leaves and they add like twigs and
like a bunch of [ __ ] like glitter and
[ __ ]
it is it is that fall feel yeah we're in
fall already
yeah except for la like we don't really
hit
fall summer so i guess that's why these
were it was 98 yesterday is pretty high
our like two or like last week um i woke
up and
i couldn't see the mountains by outside
he didn't even react
because it was so foggy
from the fire right no no no no no no no
it wasn't the fire it was just like it
was just
yeah you know the fire's still going
though yeah but it went away from where
we were at
but it's still going yeah it's burning
somewhere else nothing more up north
right napa valley
yeah it's upside down all the wine no
they got one that's still going right on
top
of yeah the angel is crisp
yes so much smoke so the official
product description for this
bag of leaves it says bring the outdoors
indoors and brighten up your home with
freshly picked flowers that reflect the
colors of the season we source the best
blooms from expert growers
and handle them gently on their journey
to our store so they look beautiful for
longer
i just i can't imagine like walking into
someone's house and like oh your leaves
where did you get these leaves they look
so nice watch when you have a kid you're
gonna start talking about leaves
watch is that what y'all do no
watch all right yo what's that art store
michaels yeah they got twigs and stuff
that's true
yeah you go buy some twigs cause it's
like thanksgiving and
somehow people want to use twigs okay so
if you're talking about like a dinner
display i get it because i was trying to
imagine where someone would just put
leaves yeah
that's packaged it looks like it's
rolled up like that's the finished
product like you don't take it out of
there
yeah let's go on a date and pain you go
on a date and you give her a bag of
leaves like it looks like a salad
yeah it does look like a salad like a
mixed green oh you know what
one time when i was younger when i was
in thailand paid six bucks for a salad
there was this
restaurant where they took big ass
leaves like that and they deep fried it
and they use it as like almost like
a chip to put like the little like uh
meat situation on you know like almost
like a like a ceviche-ish type situation
but it was on leaves
leviticus
yeah so i get it if they were like if
they if they weren't gonna die
immediately yeah they were artificial
leaves and you're charging this much for
it
and you have them in a bag like okay but
the fact that they're just
straight straight-up leaves that are
going to die in it like a few hours
probably who knows
that's just kind of crazy how are you
doing a shelf life of leaves leaves
already yeah
i don't know how long do they survive
for they don't survive as long as
flowers maybe when they because
you see them dry on the floor and they
look really pretty so maybe like
over time they change and then they just
get really dry and crisp pretty yeah i
like stepping on leaves because it's
like i'm stepping on chips [ __ ]
yeah but like nature you don't feel bad
about it
you can make a song out of it and i wish
we had more of that around here because
they're so fun i've always wanted to
jump in a pile of leaves after raking
the whole place and then just have a
huge ass pile that's
always well go to costco for one of
these you could buy
a box shove them on the floor you know
dump them wait a couple days
dream come true right there well we have
uh in la we have
a mountain of potato chip bags that make
the same sound
as leaves that you could jump on oh it
says guaranteed for five days you could
have five days
five days of green leaf you could sell
anything yeah like there's just random
[ __ ] all right it was that thing of um
of nothing i think you get for the
person that has everything and it's like
a
globe and it's nothing in it and you
give them that
wow and you're like i give you nothing
yeah for life
yeah so like gimmicky that i like it
i used to like you ever give like those
broke but like loving gifts like here's
a coupon
for a massage yeah yeah or something i
did that here i was
here's a coupon for i'll go down on you
for now or something
dad happy father's day
this is all they had left sorry dad i
thought they had left
you'd be scared when he cashes it in oh
god you're right yeah no that one
is one thing that wasn't a good day yeah
you get a
card from [ __ ] like spencer's or
something and it's the only one left
with the furry handcuffs yeah oh i had a
homie one time as
like a prank gag for his birthday and
he's like recording
and um it was for his mom's birthday she
opens up this bag it's like all right
mom's from me and she opens it up
it's lingerie she's like what the he's
like yeah
hey everyone's all confused at the
birthday party it was really good
that is really good that's embarrassing
yeah it's fun
is she really conservative she was
pretty religious yeah
oh [ __ ] maybe that's why it's so funny
she's religious but she's also you know
she
she gets it yeah yeah that's cool she
wore it that night
my mom wouldn't get it like if i got my
mom lingerie she's so
maybe that's where my asperger's comes
from but she's so like
logical she's like how am i supposed to
stay warm in this lace
[Laughter]
does she know what lingerie is for or
she'll be like ooh underwear
yeah she wants to see his underwear yeah
you've seen how she dresses you know she
doesn't know what i'm doing
that's true damn burn it's not a burn at
all not even close it's just very
observational facts
dresses for comfort yes she's like this
is soft i like
yeah she's like a kid oh wow
another burn two burns on your mom
hey hey wow you're going to cause a
[ __ ]
argument over here i meant in a nice way
stop i like her
oh she don't love her oh
[Music]
how do you think your parents would
react to a bag of leaves like that
they would talk so much [ __ ] they're
like why the [ __ ] did you give me this
exactly what the [ __ ] is this [ __ ]
my mom would love it because she's like
you never got me anything
you're a bad son i'm just kidding i
bought her things
like i bought her a rolex oh i know
right but that was the only gift
i haven't i haven't got her anything in
like the last three years no i think
that's
i was hoping that it would last a good
time it should last a lifetime
real rolex yeah it was real i gave i
like that you thought he would give her
a fake one i gave my stepdad
like a citizen watch though oh because i
was like you don't earn you don't
deserve you haven't had that many years
with me yet
so you're getting maybe a seiko next
time yeah from the calculator one
yeah the timex yeah the casios
i like to uh i like to give my mom
flowers on
my birthday because i feel like she's
the one that put in the work she should
be that one she gave
birth to me so i'm like here thank you
for giving birth yo that's
that's what your mom wanted yeah but my
mom wants me
on my knees and like bowie she asked for
too much from you
yeah i mean i think it's pretty fair ass
really you had you for nine months
yo continue idea though oh all right
dude i want you to bow to me
do it with tyka she wanted to get
pregnant
to have me so yeah
yeah why is it our fault that they were
horny yeah
mom
horny ass mom i feel like every single
child has had that thought
right have you guys had that thought of
like the [ __ ] i didn't ask to be born
when i have to do these chores
like why do i don't tie it to the chores
because to me i'm like yeah that's like
we're a team
the part that i don't get is you have to
be thankful that i gave birth to you
this day so it's the things that are
associated with that one day
i'm like i didn't even have a choice
so but you did i did it was like but my
life
sucks though why should i be grateful
for it why did you you brought me into
this [ __ ] hole
into a shitty situation dude
[Music]
[Music]
you